brandon judd is a border patrol agent
and president of the national border
patrol council welcome brandon it's good
to have you here now brandon i
understand that uh we are seeing in some
areas
15 to 18 000 people uh a day
well that's that's what that's what is
expected once title 42 goes away right
now we're encountering between seven to
eight thousand people but to put that in
perspective when we arrest three
thousand people per day our resources
are completely stretched thin once we
hit 5000 a day we're at a crisis when we
hit what we're at right now we've
basically given up all control of the
border we've ceded control to the
criminal cartels they have now flooded
us our resources are pulled out of the
field were put into administrative
duties such as processing hospital watch
transport um
detention security that's where most of
our agents are right now and that's the
problem we have gaps in our border that
at some points we have stretches of 250
miles that aren't even patrolled right
now simply because this administration's
policies are allowing um this to take
place well the amazing part of it is i
understand in the last couple of weeks
you've made busts of fentanyl coming
across the border which would kill
millions of people had it not been
intercepted by you guys so first of all
kudos to uh to the border patrol for
this but the sad part about this is you
know that that you're called upon to do
things that you shouldn't be doing
instead of protecting the border you're
called upon to do social service jobs
well what's really sad about that is
those fentanyl busts those have just
been by happenstance
pure coincidence that we were able to
stumble upon them we just don't have the
resources in the field to actually go
after the cartels and they're dangerous
products they're bringing across we also
have 2 000 godaways every single day and
that's what's known that's what we
actually detect we don't know who those
people are where they're coming from
what their intentions are here in the
united states but because we don't have
the resources in the field they're able
to get away that is what is so scary
about border security we must know what
is coming into the united states we've
got to be able to protect against the
dangerous drugs um to in order to save
our children from overdose deaths the
most that we've ever had last year in
fiscal year 21 over a hundred thousand
we've got to be able to secure our
border from threats that are coming
across and right now we just can't do
that
well you know i must tell you that i
have received some letters from the
western sheriff's association along with
the southern sheriff's association
the western states sheriff's association
i have several letters i don't know if
we have the full screen of those letters
uh it it okay i'm being told that we
don't where the sheriff's of basically
no confidence from the whole southern
and most of the western uh uh border uh
no confidence in mayorkas and they're
they're desperate to get some help on
this especially when 42 is eliminated uh
then the local towns aren't going to be
able to handle any of this if you've got
15 000 people coming in a day the local
towns will be destroyed
yeah i work with multiple i've worked
very closely with multiple sheriffs and
they're extremely scared about what's
going to happen and they're they're
really frustrated we're all frustrated
because there is a solution and they
know that there's a solution when
jinsaki on on monday said that they'll
work with anybody that's not true that's
a lie they know what the solutions are
they refuse to implement them thank you
so much for being with us we appreciate
it and good luck thank you stay safe hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else